well hey there buckaroos that's the voice
of Woody but it's not who you think it is
howdy I'm Jace Diehl and today I'm here with the
voice of a legendary Cowboy who's been in toys
theme parks live shows computer games and video
things and Jim just he works on those all year
long it's the legendary voice of Woody Jim Hanks
thanks for joining me Jim legendary oh let no
doubt come on okay all right all right so how many
years wait 28 29 years I think 29. wow okay I went
and did the first toy in 94 before the first movie
came out so did I get everything on the list I got
the toys theme park like you've done your career
is extensive with Woody I did one uh short after
the fourth movie came out called Lamp Life yes
okay and that was the voice there yeah more or
less I was like going oh okay I'm actually doing
real stuff now animated by Pixar right yeah all
the way so let's go back to the beginning how
did you become the voice my agent basically said
Disney wants to you to go in and do this stuff and
this thing your brother's doing and okay I don't
remember actually auditioning I just remember
going into this tiny little booth and having
a little bit of a scratch of you know Tom having
done it Sarge you seen Slinky yeah I think I had
I don't know seven eight lines classic
you're my favorite Deputy hey howdy hey
snake in my boot sure I'd like to join your
posse boys but first I'd like to sing you
a little song a few things like that and uh
walked out and went alright well that's cool
29 years later I'm still doing it
so I'm I feel incredibly fortunate
at the time or before that did you know you could
do that voice you could hit it I never really knew
that my voice was as similar to Toms I have since
then seen videos of myself and probably I'll do
it here too uh where I watch myself and go oh
my God yeah I do sound like him even if I'm not
trying but no I was never going hey Tom say that
again Tom does this thing where he simultaneously
pushes with its diaphragm and he pushes it up to
his nose so I'm talking like this but Tom talks
like this he's like here at the same time it's
down deep but it's also up here hi I'm Tom and and
for me whenever I'm at a mic and I'm finding uh I
go hey hey hey hey and I can find him I find that
that the hey has an explosiveness that takes me to
Tom especially early on Woody has a lot of power
I've always said that my Woody is my impression
of Tom yelling at his kid okay it's like get
down from there that's that is that is Woody
it's Buzz the same thing yeah always straining
to go somewhere yeah yeah and it when it's like
that it it'll blow you out fast when toys come
to life to infinity and beyond Toy Story when you
were going into the first project had you heard of
Toy Story like were there trailers out at the time
or no okay no I think it was far enough advanced
because they were making the toy and I think the
first three toy stories came out on Thanksgiving
Happy Thanksgiving set right before Christmas
and people oh my God I have to have every Toy
Story toy I did know that Tom was doing
something and at the time you know Pixar
was what they had Tin Toy and a couple things
I mean not very many people knew who Pixar was
or even what CG animation was right yeah computer
generated oh that's gonna look weird Walt Disney
Pictures presents the first ever computer animated
motion picture event it was the beginning of an
era and for me it's been really fortunate that for
whatever reason Woody has become one of their more
iconic characters and so one of the things that's
fortunate for me is that they will ask the Woody
character to do a lot of different things coming
up Woody's yours now and I went oh really I did
the voice for this do I really have to stand in
line and there's also word that they're thinking
about making more don't touch that dial we'll
be right back to Woody's Roundup after this
brief message Casetify has done collabs with many
brands in the past including Toy Story and their
latest collab is with Spider-Man and I will say
Spider-Man X Casetify may be the best collab yet
like all Casetify cases these have drop protection
but this time with some of the most unique designs
yet the textures especially on these two mirror
cases are awesome and really pop in person there's
also clear cases that showcase Spider-Man swinging
and a collage Daily Bugle articles these are all
my personal favorites but there's many more to
choose from including a whole Venom collection
so check out the entire Spider-Man X Casetify
collection by clicking the link in the video
description below and I want to thank Casetify for
sponsoring this video and now let's get back to it
do you know what the first project you did was it
the toy you said that yeah the first pull toy was
the first one the talking and possible figures of
Woody and Buzz Lightyear my name's Woody each sold
separately I think the second one was the ice
capades oh the Disney on Ice stuff yeah I've heard
you have to like enunciate more and like project
because you're in a huge arena well enunciation
uh was really important at the beginning because
like even the pull toy was kind of mushy sounding
compared to what they have now oh okay yeah so I
did have to say there's a snake in my boot and hit
the T really hard and things like that because
it comes out you know so you have to really uh
it really enunciate and yeah you have to over
enunciate because it's in this giant auditorium
with a lot of ice so the sound is bouncing around
weird but you know the painful part is singing
the first time was absolutely terrifying oh God
I'm not a singer okay and it was the music because
you're in a different voice it's not really you
singing well that actually when I did the ice
capades it was terrifying and I was just I just
got through it it wasn't until I did uh the the
Woody with the guitar strumming singing Woody
and he sings Home on the Range I was struggling
through that and it was same kind of thing I was
trying to sing well which was not gonna happen and
uh at some point I just went hold on let me just
try this more in character and then that was it
that was the time where I got it yeah so
that so that was like you know kind of a
landmark going oh I can do this yeah all
right cool howdy Partners climb aboard
we were recording the Midway Mania and I was like
on my third uh session you know and sometimes
sessions go for you know four or six hours so it
could be pretty intense they were really having
a hard time because they kept saying Woody has
to be able to talk to two and three-year-olds I
was trying to do everything I could and there
was a couple of little examples in the movies
where he's hey buddy come on kind of thing and
uh it just wasn't working and we were like in the
third session and I went can I say something and
they went yeah what I said the thing about Woody
is Woody never talks down to anybody Woody to
me is like everybody's favorite teacher who
talks to you as a person and they went okay let's
try that and I did the entire ride in 45 minutes
because we just did it like that yeah it just
shows like you have the voice but you know
the character integrity to keep it going
you know that's awesome have you been to
you gotta have been to Disneyland and Disney World
to see I've only been to Disneyland yeah okay I
have not been to Disney World I've been and saw
Toy Story Land and you're right up in center yeah
50 foot tall Woody yeah he's not the biggest
one oh there's a I think it's a hundred foot
tall one in Hong Kong oh another Woody yeah wow
they showed me pictures of it and I went that's
a little scary yeah and your voice is booming
throughout the whole land I'd like to give you
a nice big Andy's backyard welcome what was it
like going on Midway Mania it's so weird yeah
it's so weird yeah you're in what the project
you are like you're playing it you're in the
ride you're yeah what was that like yeah I just
go stop telling me what to do oh I'm talking to
myself uh yeah it's it's trippy it's always trippy
there was a a time in the early 2000s I was also
the voice of Toys R Us Jeffrey the Giraffe that's
right hello welcome to Toys R Us uh can I help
you my voice was everywhere there wow Jeffrey
dolls that my voice came out of I'm on the PA
system or I could walk over and start pulling a
string on a Woody doll I was all over the place
the king of Toys R Us that's awesome that was a
great job it always cracks me up when somebody
says oh I went to Disneyland well I know what's
coming next you were everywhere do you have any
Disney perks when you go to the parks one time we
were there shortly after Midway Mania started and
it was just you know line like that all these
people you see behind me are here for the grand
opening of Toy Story Mania and we hear it's a
five hour wait in line and I walked up to one
of the persons went hey um I did the voice for
this do I really have to stand in line and they
went and so they disappear and then somebody
with the you know one of the jackets shows up
and go okay Mr Hanks here you go so that was
kind of cool that was the only time I pulled
that that's awesome so yeah we got theme
parks ice shows how about the video games
I feel like those would be really difficult
so you have I'm sure a ton of lines for every
situation the character can be in and how about
the efforts like when you get oh yeah the efforts
are yeah you explain what those are it's just
the sounds like okay he's landing and okay you
know and we need it like he's Landing from 10
feet to just jumping off a curb so it's like uh
you know everything in between and I remember
going in and working on one it was the first
time I ever met John Ratzenberger which was
really great he's a super nice guy oh you look
good hey you lose some weight but I I go in and
it was old style you know very two-dimensional
he's just running from one side of the screen and
not really into it like you know like the Kingdom
Hearts thing which is amazing but I remember at
one point he says okay now he's going to climb
up this rope and then he's going to jump over
here then he's going to kick this thing off off
the and then a long list of things I had to do I
said I'm scratching okay and they say and action
and I do this whole thing and I'm
watching the guys in the room just going
behind the glass and I went all right I'm doing
it right yeah one take wonder you got it yeah
it was it was yeah it was fun we leave all
the explosive stuff like the efforts and the
yeehaws are I always do at the end because
it could be kind of rough on your voice and
stuff like that with meeting John Ratzenberger
have you ever recorded with anyone else in the
cast or is it always alone it's almost always
alone um I did not record with him there was
one time we did it and it was for Saturday morning
interstitials we're clear good playdate everybody
and that one was fun because they had
everybody who was doing it and there was
this one guy who they had kind of stretched
you know the shark who finds his hat and go
they made his character and they
did it where he was Robert Shaw from
Jaws and when they found him his batteries were
dead so funny that's great oh my God it was so
funny oh so that one you did with the group yeah
we were all in the group he's just sitting there
and he's telling his story it was so hard to not
just absolutely crack up it was so fun so we have
Toy Story one through four do you ever go back and
record like specific lines from one or specific
from four and is there a difference between
those because again 29 years yeah there is I
recently did a thing I forget what the project
was but I was doing like a sound alike for all
these different lines that came out of all the
four movies and so I'm starting in one and I have
to be young Tom you know and and then I'm getting
these directions going for the lines from you know
four or three going uh Jim can you get a little
closer to old Tom here and it's like woah that's
a weird direction you can't teach this old toy
new tricks if you if you notice he's having more
conversations that aren't powerful yeah he's not
trying to control the room you know kind of find
a moving buddy if you haven't found one get one
now he's having conversations where he's just kind
of sitting there going hey so what happened
to you Bo Peep so how long were you in here
I would think with uh with all the everything
you've done with all the different categories
that it's more prevalent when a new movie comes
out is it like oh like really crazy when three
came out or when four came out yeah 19 or 18
whenever the the year the four came out was
crazy because then they do all the commercial
tie-ins and stuff like that it's all clear
those are always good years it's slowed down a
little bit but it's been picking up again and
there's also word they're thinking about making
more I don't know where they're going to go with
it but those people from Pixar are freaking
geniuses so I'm going to assume it's going to
be something really cool and I remember after four
granted this has changed now but after four I was
having lunch with Tom and we were talking about
talking you know and he you know he thought he
was done he said well Woody's yours now and I went
oh really well I guess it is isn't it okay but not
so much and he's back undo it no no I feel like
your your legacy with Woody is just monumental
because of how many things you've done and how
prevalent your voice is I think too uh you know
some of it is Tom's fame you know I'm you know Tom
I I say this often Tom is arguably one
of the most famous people on the planet
so that has something to do with it you know and
Pixar again geniuses Tom wasn't he was successful
but he wasn't who he is now yeah well to
end off the interview since you said that
you do yeehaws at the end do you mind saying
bye to to the viewers and giving us a little
yee-haw with it I'm going to have to moisturize
here first I haven't tried it so okay okay
and normally I can get high but it's just not
going to happen no that was it that sounded
exactly like it well hey there buckaroos it's
been a great show so we'll see you next time
same cowboy time same cowboy channel tune in
next week for the exciting conclusion Woody's
finest hour one time Tom and I were
up visiting my mother and we called
my other brother we were just blabbing
away and my brother Larry finally says I
I just got to say this is like listening
to dueling Woody's okay that's great